pues los habitantes de aquí piden mucho
a pedro sánchez porque se sienten muy
decepcionados nos han contado que se
sienten abandonados completamente por
españa' de momento pedro sánchez el
martes pasado en el consejo de ministros
ha decidido dar 10 5 millones de euros
para realojar a la población que se ha
quedado sin casa o la población más
afectada pero aquí aún no se ha recibido
este dinero por eso no es suficiente
para los habitantes ya que los daños
materiales aquí son absolutamente
enormes 7 ciencias hectáreas
completamente destruidas más de 1000
edificios que están dañados por por esto
por la cumbre vieja el volcán y ahora se
superan los 400 millones de euros de
daños materiales está este volcán ya
hace que 10 por ciento de la isla esté
en parte destruida